il ya plusieurs types de prévention d'un
visage mais aussi dans dans les
situations où par exemple les pleurs de
la prévention ordinaire simple on part
l'animation par exemple il tombe à voir
de la prévention par rapport à un acte
posé de délinquance qui est déjà posé
une toile peut y avoir des prétentions
ce qu'on appelle aussi la prévention de
la récidive faire que quelqu'un qui a
fait une bêtise ne recommence pas donc
la prévention c'est un terme vraiment
qui regroupe de très nombreuses motions
et de très nombreux accents choc
d'action ici l'action c'est d'accueillir
ou peut se reposer faire le point
s'amuser aussi l'été en canoë kayak
l'hiver avec des soirées à thème pas
question de vivre de convention il faut
que la fois rentables pas question non
plus de classification
les bus est avant tout un lieu de
rencontres et de loisirs comme n'importe
quel j et parmi les clients
trois à quatre personnes en difficulté
sur l'action qu'on peut avoir voté à la
tourbière des bases celles écoute faut
être à l'écouté des gens pouvoir les
écouter longuement pour essayer de
trouver une solution c'est une solution
qui soit qui soit la plus importante
c'est ce qui est le plus difficile pour
vous dans la prévention
je ne peux pas porter de jugement se
gare d'eau de porter un jugement qui
souvent pourrait être actif et un petit
peu dommageable pour la personne qui est
en face de soi avant de s'occuper de la
douce des pelouses je vais gagner saiss
et éducateur spécialisé à plano a pour
lui des pensées pays
et tout il vaut mieux malines jégou
les foules la passion il ne suffit pas
seulement de trouver des solutions et
des financements
on peut pas obliger quelqu'un à se
réinsérer dans une société si on n'a pas
envie de s'intégrer simplement dans une
société sinan attentes
je crois que la solution nous on peut
être des conseillers mais la solution
appartient toujours à l'individu qu avec
lequel on travaille pour la double
écluse jeu c'est gasquet a plein de
projets par exemple restaurer une
péniche pour en faire un garage à
bateaux ou encore mettre en place une
grande salle d'activités canton conseil
communal son effort pour 1988 va surtout
se porter sur les 9 13 ans en
développant les animations de terrain
planoise et mon rapport avec pourquoi
pas des sorties nettes mais clusaz
m